[Music]
foreign
look at you
[Music]
one more
foreign
[Music]
to me
it's happening for me
the cycles never ending that's why now I
befriend it
what you live at night time we'll come
find you in the sunrise
mornings matter
[Music]
thankful for the day to come oh
and even when it's Miserables
arms
[Music]
I don't wanna morning glider
and Eva when is miserable
[Music]
thankful for the days
check check
welcome everyone
um now's a great time to grab your seat
and I think we have we have two extra
seats up here people are still looking
for seats
um
this is also a great time to silence
your phone if you have one of those
um
my name is Andrew Warner I'm the
producer of our talks here at the
interval thank you for coming out
tonight
um one of our guiding principles here at
long now is that in order to get to a
future that we want to live in we must
first be able to imagine it
unfortunately it turns out it's much
easier to imagine dystopia than a
thriving civilization
joining us tonight are two of the most
compelling authors in science fiction
trying to imagine worlds that we might
actually want to live in Becky Chambers
and Annalee newest
falcon
well hello thanks so much for coming out
and
um
so let's just get right down to it and
uh talk about dystopia a little bit but
first I'm going to have some water it's
very important to hydrate yeah
save the world as we're gonna do yeah
exactly and water is I think part of a
world that we want to live in for us yes
for humans you know we're mostly water
so when we were coming up with the idea
for this conversation we really we both
knew immediately that we wanted to talk
about this idea of resisting dystopia
both in the real world context but also
in fiction
um and so I want to start by asking you
about what it what do you think dystopia
is and what does it mean to be resisting
it like what is this thing that we're
talking about that we want to push back
on
so uh the very easy question of how to
Define dystopia
dystopia is a world that is
fundamentally broken uh it is a world in
which
um compassion is thin on the ground it's
a world in which
no one wants to live and in fact it's
quite difficult to do so
um it's a place in which survival is the
only end uh that you really have the
ability to fight for
um
resisting it resisting it does not mean
uh we're just going to tell a story
about somewhere else we're just going to
close our eyes and stick our fingers in
our ears and uh focus on you know the
most rose-colored glasses version of
this instead resistance is action
resistance is struggle resistance is a
fight so if you are going to resist
dystopia resist
um oppression resist fascism any of
these things that are very much part of
the world as we live in now
um it requires effort and it requires
honesty uh and a lot of other traits
that we're going to talk about in the
next 58 minutes or so
I wanted to add to that that
um one of the things about dystopia is
that it is a real world phenomenon it's
something that we associate with fascism
and oppression and closed regimes but
it's also a type of Storytelling and you
know as science fiction writers we are
immersed in a world where people often
tell us that dystopian writing is the
most realistic kind of writing and that
if we want to tell a story that is going
to help our readers our audiences
grapple with what's going on in the real
world we need to tell them a dark
up story where everyone dies and the
world is ashes at the end
um I once went to a hacker conference
where people were talking a lot about
the Grim meat hook future and
um that's basically you know I think
held up as this ideal in in narrative
and so I think part of resisting
dystopia isn't just the hard work of
politically resisting in the real world
but also resisting the urge to turn our
stories about the future into these very
one note
non-nuanced visions of where humanity
and our world could go so that's another
piece of what we're resisting in our
work I think absolutely I mean the real
world and fiction go hand in hand they
are they are an arroboros
um I have a real bone to pick with
um this thing that is is very common in
the here and now and not just in
um Science Fiction and Fantasy but in
storytelling as a whole right now um
this idea that that cynicism equals
sophistication right that if we're going
to tell stories to adults for adults
that it has to be the Grim meat hook
future
um that this is inevitable somehow I
think that that is uh
uh just profoundly wrong it's profoundly
wrong on every level because
um you're you're you're creating the
self-fulfilling prophecy you're saying
that hope is something that belongs to
children that Joy is something that
belongs to children and if that's the
case what are we fighting
four like what's the point you know I I
really think that just breeds nihilism
if the only stories we are telling about
the future even if it is in a fictional
context because if the only places we
are imagining and escaping to are places
in which the grimmest possibility is the
only outcome
what do we have to hope for what do we
have to live for you know and so that's
where I think I'm biased of course but
why I think it's important
um not to say that those kinds of
stories don't have value sometimes in
order to confront
um things that are horrifying things
that
um are real and scary and damaging we do
need to lean in to that you just need to
sometimes grab it by the caller and look
at it in the face uh as hard as you can
but if you don't have a Counterpoint to
that
um I think it just starts to poison you
after a while which you know sugar does
too if all you had was
if all you had was hopeful stories if
all you had was and everything works out
and they all lived happily ever after
that's not going to help you out either
but I think you know the the basis of a
nutritious fictional meal is to have
um I didn't mean to keep continuing with
this metaphor but here we are uh but you
know to have a healthy balanced
ecosystem of Storytelling you've got to
have the other side as well yeah I'm
still really disappointed about the
whole thing where you can't just eat
sugar all the time so you know thanks
for
bringing it down
um but I think I mean to continue with
what Becky's saying I think what's
really important I think for both of us
in our fiction is avoiding a binary
where there's either dystopia or Utopia
because I think that's the other trap
that we get into as storytellers not
just as fictional storytellers but also
as people who are trying to innovate or
people who are trying to you know write
non-fiction about the future is that
we're sort of told okay it's either
going to be all sugar or it's just going
to be this realistic Grim future and the
fact is that the future is going to be
just as messy and nuanced as the present
you know there's going to be people
doing really cool stuff there's going to
be people trying to kill the people who
are doing the cool stuff and there's
going to be everything in between right
there's going to be mixed spaces where
lots of those people come together and
so I often tell people that I'm a topian
writer which means I'm just writing
about a place like now
um and you know one of the the things
about dystopian writing and for a minute
I want to pick on a specific example uh
because a lot of people have been
revisiting the handmaid's tale
um for obvious reasons
um not just the television show but also
real world politics and one of the
things that Margaret Atwood has said
about that book is that she sees it as
realistic because every single thing in
it has happened at some point in history
which is actually unrealistic because
there's no point in history when every
single bad thing ever happened all at
once
um and I'm not and this is not to pick
on on that book I mean it's a fantastic
book it's an incredibly useful allegory
for us to think about what's happening
to women's bodies and women's rights but
in terms of what dystopia is it reminds
us that dystopia is an allegory you know
it's just a fan or a fable it's not an
actual real world scenario and so that's
the thing that again we're trying to
avoid when we actually try to write a
realistic future
um so maybe we could talk a little bit
about these realistic Futures that we're
imagining that are more nuanced um and
that are kind of a reaction against
um dystopia and so
um one thing that both of us are really
interested in and I want to toss this to
you to talk about first is
um having a really
um a canvas a temporal canvas that's
very broad like riding across a huge
span of time which appear we are at the
long now which is devoted to that idea
so what is it about having that broad
time frame that you think lends itself
to a more nuanced vision of a of a
future world I think it's very simple I
have
um
in all things ever just an issue with
protagonists
um
because we don't have any like if you if
you really want to write something
realistic you don't have a protagonist
now granted I have written things with a
protagonist because with a novella like
you only have so much space
um
but I think if you really want to paint
a picture of a world where it is more
Cooperative where there is more of a
collective mindset where nothing is
perfect but things are working at least
better than here
um
it makes more sense in my mind to show
that this is a collective effort over
time and over
um you know often a large like
geographical space or Galactic space
depending on which books we're talking
about
um that you have multiple povs
um which we both like to play with in
our work
um because it's not just one person's
story there isn't going to be a savior a
chosen one who pulls us out of this you
know I I am very intentionally writing
um
to counter this idea of you know the the
genius that's going to save everybody I
think the people that are going to save
everybody are the very ordinary people
doing very very small things
um to help each other and to be kind and
to be open to one another I think that
that's the only thing that's going to
push us forward is to have as much of
that as possible so those those are the
stories that I'm interested in telling
um because yeah if if we're gonna keep
going the only way to do it is together
try it as that sounds but that's the
we're a social species we have to do
that
yeah and I think that's another aspect
of realism is acknowledging that we
actually are a collective and social
species and that it isn't going to be
you know
um Paula tradies who like you know does
some drugs and like rides the worm right
I mean it's like yeah it there's there's
more involved there's all the worm
caretakers there's all the people that
are like you know back home maintaining
the family if the world could be saved
by a special white boy doing drugs
[Laughter]
we would be there
so true
yeah I think like one of the things that
appeals to me about having a story that
takes place over a very long period of
time like my most recent novel The
terraformers takes place over you know
more than a thousand years it's a
multi-generational story is that I think
it allows us to dream a little bit
beyond the confines of a single life and
one of the things that I think tempts us
into this dystopian mindset is that we
are actually trapped in a really short
period of time
um we're we're stuck with the time we're
given and sometimes the time is really
shitty sometimes things start out
seeming really great and get really
shitty and we never live to see things
get better again but when you have a
story that lets you see how one
generation's rebellions or resistance
gets passed on to the next generation
and that generation does something new
with it and resists oppressive Authority
in a new way you're able in your
imagination to understand stand how
Justice and how positive social
transformation can happen over this
broader span of time and I really think
increasingly the older I get that one of
the most valuable aspects of
Storytelling is allowing us to see that
bigger canvas and to understand that our
lives are connected to something much
much bigger whether it's other people or
our ancestors or the people who come
after us and especially as we're dealing
with environmental disasters on the
scale that we're looking at right now we
have to be thinking about those other
people in the future and remembering
that what we do now Will can either be a
gift to them or a giant turd for them or
maybe the turd will be a gift because
maybe it's like compost you know like
maybe it'll be like the turd gift I
don't know okay anyway
I'm sorry
yeah
I mean this is
um when I was reading the terraformers
and I realized oh we're gonna be we're
going to be jumping through time that
was when I got really really excited
um because that that's what the story is
about that's what the story of
um not not just your story but like the
story the story of us
um
foreign
truth that the better Futures we are
working toward hoping for wishing for
might not belong to us that we might
never see them
that's that's a tricky thing but I
actually find a very odd sort of comfort
in it I know that sounds weird but I I
really do feel that just sort of
accepting that
I am not going to see that you know but
that maybe some somebody down the road
uh will see the the fruits of our
actions together
that gives it kind of takes the pressure
off because otherwise you have this
feeling of just like I hate it here so
much I'm just gonna kick my heels and
you know like I wish it wasn't like this
I want to get out of this but if you
just accept that history has always kind
of sucked and the here and now also kind
of sucks
um and that's just part of life and life
is still wonderful within that I really
um this is not a spoiler of your book
don't worry Don't panic but like there's
a there's a very wonderful note
um at the end of their book like the
last moments of the book are one that
really talked to speak to you know how
the the road ahead is going to be hard
but like that's why it's important to
appreciate
this moment now yeah and that's that's
what it is that's what it's all about
and so if you can to bring it back to
storytelling if you can tell a story in
which you show the small things not the
big Galactic Victory necessarily those
stories are awesome but like this the
little things that the moment you have
with somebody else the love you show for
one other person that will never get
written down anywhere that no one else
will remember but that that those points
in the Long March of time of progress of
you know two one step forward two steps
back
those matter just as much as the big
victory and so that in when I see that
in your writing and I know I do it in my
writing too that focusing on the little
beautiful things amidst the big story
The Big setting the the um the
all-encompassing timeline that most of
these people don't get to see
I think that's what it's all about I
think that's what's so fantastic about
your robot and monk books is that um
which are for sale back there and you
should check them out
um because they're they're exactly about
those small moments and you know you've
we have these tea cups and teapot up
here because the monk in these books
this tea monk basically what they're
doing is they're going around and having
tea with people and having conversations
and I wonder if you could just talk a
little bit about building that idea and
how you see that fitting into this
larger picture of building a huge world
that is better for us to live in so uh
Dex the character in question uh as
mentioned is it is a Traveling Monk and
they go about uh dispensing teeth and
that's it you can just sit and have a
cup of tea you can talk if you like you
can talk to other people or you can just
sit
um Dex is a disciple of in this world
there are six Gods uh because I say so
um and
um the three there's the parent gods and
the and the the uh child gods and so the
child Gods um they uh you've got a god
that is essentially Art and Science
you've got one that is uh tools and
machines constructs
um Dex has God allele is the god of
small comforts
and the reason this is such an important
part of this world's religion this
world's belief system uh the saying goes
that find the strength to do both do
both being what to pursue Truth uh
however you can be that through ART or
science
um and to invent tools that will help
you along the way you cannot do those
things without rest you cannot do those
things without comfort you cannot do
this into that beauty I wanted to create
a world in which
the smallest things are seen as
something sacred you know whether it be
a nap a good meal a hug from a friend
where those are actually
you know the these these venerable
things
um because they are because they're
everything you know
um I wanted to say that these are not
the luxury that awaits you at the end of
the day these are not something that you
have to earn this is actually fuel the
moments we spend together the um the
time you take for yourself or give to
others that's fuel that is how we do the
hard work
um and so for me a cup of tea was the
easiest stand-in for that a cup of tea
is nothing this cup of tea is Lovely by
the way
but but it's not important you know in
in the grand scheme of things it's a cup
of tea right uh and yet a cup of tea can
change your whole day a cup of tea that
somebody hands you when you're sad or
when you're sick or when you're just
tired a cup of tea that somebody makes
for you is a surprise
um can change everything it can change
your whole outlook you know so it just
seemed a a natural fit to to make that
part of their
um not just their religious practice but
their entire life that they are devoted
to this very simple thing that in the
grand scheme seems like it doesn't
matter but it actually really does yeah
I really like that idea of elevating the
notion of taking a rest and of taking a
pause to the same level that you elevate
Innovation or that you elevate Art and
Science because we live in a culture
right now where productivity is so
fetishized that the idea that something
like a cup of tea would be held up as
like something on par with like getting
all your work done and filing all that
code like this is a world where if
someone is filing too much code you know
if somebody is committing too much code
someone's going to come along and say
like you need to go rest like this is
not healthy it's not okay and no one's
expecting you to do this this is not
right
um and so I think that's part of
building that balance that sense of a
world where yeah we can still have all
the cool Tech but we also need to have
these moments that are devoted to
something else and that brings me to
another thing that I think both of us
have explored a lot in our work which is
breaking down a distinction between the
natural and the technological and I
think a lot of um science fiction
thinks of technology is associated with
progress and nature as associated with
the past unless it's some kind of
synthetic nature and we're like you know
doing genome splicing and you know
crispr cas9 blah blah that's okay but
that's also technological right
um and both of us are really interested
in um thinking about uh robot characters
who are people robots who love nature
um how nature is really a part of
um you know the future basically and not
just synthetic nature
um so maybe you can talk a little bit
about that like why is why is nature and
the environment so important for this
for this pushing back against dystopia
uh first start because we need it to
survive that's it's a pretty important
thing
um but I I
Monk and robot was very much intended as
a the binary in a lot of different
ways
um I uh I I this idea that
nature you know as a concept and
Technology are Polar Opposites that they
are incompatible that this is a zero-sum
game
is ridiculous
um technology is just tools it's it's
tools we can use them for lots of
different things we can use them for
good or for bad or for neutral it's just
tools
um and
we do not have to be using uh extractive
modes of consumption to make said tools
we do not have to be deploying set tools
in ways that are
um lacking in compassion lacking in
um you know a drive to build a better
Society like
technology does not have to equal money
do you know what I mean like the pursuit
of Technology
does not have to be the bottom line the
new shiniest thing it can be Let's Build
a Better World together and I don't
think that you have to uh if you want to
have a world in which you have a
thriving ecosystem in which you have
um you know a climate that is not
collapsing all around you does not mean
we have to you know have this sort of
hair shirt future either where it's like
okay we're all gonna you know just uh go
back to hunting and Gathering not to
like throw stones at hunting and
Gathering because it's awesome but like
we you can still have a house do you
know what I mean you can still wash your
clothes you can still have the internet
I I believe this firmly and so
um with Monk and robot in particular I I
really tried to paint a picture of this
is a world that in which
um the environment is respected and
understood and in which people try to
work really hard to live in concert with
it not at a distance but really in
harmony with their environment because
we're all just animals
um and it's it's good for us to
recognize that uh but in a way that is
so high-tech they have robots they have
little computers in their pockets there
are satellites that do satellite things
um
these things can co-exist and I I
obviously write fiction uh but I don't
think that that's a stretch I don't
think that that's Fantastical I think
that really truly is
a world we can achieve if we just
tweak our mindsets a little bit Yeah I
think one of the things for me that's so
interesting about writing about nature
and Technology coming together is that
ecosystems are kind of what we've been
talking about an ecosystem is a
community it's a system where all of the
pieces of it have to work together in
order to maintain a balance
um and that for me is kind of what led
me into writing a lot of characters who
are robots
um and writing characters who aren't
just regular old robots like you know
the kind that have that are sort of
bipedal and look like people
um but I have a lot of robots who have
different kinds of morphologies I have a
cyborg cow character in my latest novel
who flies because like why not
um and uh she she's actually a pretty
great character she's a scientist
um and a cow and I also have a character
I mean it happens
um and and there's also a character who
is a sentient flying train and I wanted
to think about the ways that things that
are very technological and Industrial
like public transit like a train that
carries people around all over this
planet how that's also part of the
ecosystem and so for me I felt like
giving the train a point of view or
giving the cow a point of view or giving
a moose a point of view was a way of
inviting readers to think about how
natural systems and technological
systems all are interconnected and that
each piece of it has something to bring
to a conversation or has something to
bring into this massive system and so
again being a writer I was like well the
best way to show that these pieces of
the ecosystem have something to offer is
just to give them a voice and let them
say like actually I really don't like
living in this field I want to go over
there and I'd like to fly and I would
also like to be a scientist please stop
using me for milk
um which is you know essentially what
the cows have done
um in the in a kind of backstory or the
trains are able to bargain for
themselves the trains are able to say
like actually this is the route that I
want to take and I know this because I I
talked to my writers unlike you know a
lot of public transit systems which do
not communicate with their writers about
what would be nice not that I'm calling
out any particular transit systems
um but I think that the the fiction
again it allows us to tell these stories
where the reader is invited to remember
that
um you know nature and Technology are
just pieces of a larger system that
we're also part of technology is inside
of us it's outside of us as we move into
the future my hope is that we're going
to start to see these things as being
completely interconnected and we're not
the only tool using animals either like
it's not like it's makes us special like
we make Technologies it's like come on
so do beavers I mean I know beavers are
the best they are I have what like what
is your favorite animal made technology
non-human animal-made my favorite
animal-made technology uh that would be
honeycomb good answer
it's it's stunningly beautiful and it
works so well right
um and it's it's perfect it's a perfect
structure made by these these little
these little buddies just this thing
yeah sorry okay I really like these I do
too I was just showing somebody videos
of bee waggle dances and I was like look
did you know bees have language I was
teaching my niece about B language and
she just did the waggle dance for the
rest of the day which is great look up
bee waggle dance if you haven't seen it
I bet a lot of you already have
um I wanted to um we have a few more
minutes that we're gonna talk to each
other and then we're going to open it up
to questions
um but I wanted to talk a little bit
about
um well do you want to talk about
coziness or queerness or both both okay
let's talk about Cozy queerness
um so I think I think queerness is super
cozy there it is all right made take it
away then tell us about Cozy queerness
and and um yeah okay
um so I'm okay coziness right yeah I
think that
um we could all do with being cozy I
think that we and I think that that is
it should not be a controversial thing
to say I think we should I think it
needs to be I think rest needs to be
normalized I think being comfy needs to
be normalized I think uh just indulging
in the beautiful sensory world around
you
is something nobody should feel guilty
about ever
um and I think it's especially important
in the here and now uh when we are all
exhausted and angry and not sure what's
going to happen not sure if it's ever
going to get any better just you know
being
having little pieces of yourself carved
away at every turn to be able to pick up
be it a book a video game a movie
whatever that feels like a great big hug
and we are taught that this is something
childish
um that
you're supposed to grow out of that and
that goes back to what we were talking
about about cynicism and sophistication
um with Monk and robot in particular I I
wrote it
um
in response to something I noticed that
was starting to happen in my social
circles around 2017.
you all might have been there at that
point uh
living in this golden age of books media
all of it that you can reach for
anything people started to go back to
and I'm sure a lot of you did this as
well uh Comfort shows from childhood or
watching cartoons
um and both of those things are great
those are legit things to do
um but nobody actually wanted to engage
with new stuff gritty stuff because we
were all so tired all the time and I was
like can I write something that fills
the Steven Universe re-watch or Great
British Bake Off free watch
that is intended for an adult audience
that will give you something nutritious
as well that you're you you can find a
book that meets you where you're at
right now at the age you're at
um
without you know without having to be
like well is it going to end bad I
should read the wiki first to make sure
that I'm emotionally up for this this
evening
um it goes back to comfort it goes back
to a cup of tea
um you just sometimes need a story that
tells you not necessarily that
everything's gonna be okay
but the things are okay that you are
okay
um and I think that that is in in and of
itself a type of rest yeah um I think
yeah I mean there's been um for those of
you who are science fiction fans or pay
attention there has been a whole I would
call it a coziness revolution
um in sci-fi and it's kind of it's very
much a resistance to dystopian writing
um and uh Becky's work is often hailed
as one of the great uh you know aspects
of this coziness revolution
um malka older has a new book out uh
called the mimicking of known successes
which is also a very cozy uh Space Opera
it's a kind of Sherlock Holmes mystery
um Set uh in an artificial environment
that's been built around Jupiter
um people have set up these uh rings
around Jupiter that have trains running
on them and built little habitats around
the train tracks
um and it's just this it's a very like
dark things happen but things are also
quite warm and cozy and like the
characters like each other and they want
to make things better
um and the idea of cozy fiction is not
to avoid Darkness or to you know run
away from problems it really is what
what you're talking about the idea that
you know you're not going to have to
brace yourself for some horrific
destructive uh event at the end of the
day and I think you know um a lot of
Star Trek like not classic Star Trek but
like next Generation era Star Trek kind
of participates in that same narrative
structure where everyone basically wants
to do something that's honorable and
people are there for each other and at
the end of every episode like people fix
things you know like it's not it's not
like Picard if you're watching Picard
where everything is sort of broken and
more broken
um I haven't watched this season I hear
it's getting better but
um it's much more in the vein of you
know a show where it's we're we're all
there for each other
uh cozy sci-fi can be very simply summed
up as stories that tell you that the
future could be good
yeah that's it that's all it is and if
you choose to pick up a story like that
you're choosing to engage with that idea
for a while for a little while you you
are believing that the future could be
good and that the people in it will be
kind and I think that that's
um
that is the fuel we need if we're going
to get through the here and now yeah and
I think
a lot of what we've been discussed
discussing about
focusing on
focusing on rest focusing on how people
connect with each other those are big
parts of this sub-genre and they're not
necessarily focused on giant Space
Battles often they feel a little bit
like a drawing room melodrama although
there are often huge battles that are
happening like in the background and we
know about them and they're informing
the events that are going on
um but that is part of admitting that
the future might be okay is
acknowledging that actually these small
moments in our lives really do matter
you know the moment when you like win
the big case or write the big book or
like win the battle yeah those are great
moments but actually the stuff that you
remember like that's going to the beach
with your friends when you just like
said work for the day we're gonna
get high on the beach like that's it
just as memorable and just as important
um and I think that this fits into
um our final thing that I want to talk
about which is ambient queerness in
fiction which is also part of cozy
fiction and it's also part of imagining
um a more balanced future so
let's talk about it
um for me I mean it's so very simple
um coming at this as a queer woman I I
don't know why I would write a future
that didn't have people like me and mine
in it and I I think that um
regardless of which series I'm talking
about because I've done this in all of
these having a future in which you don't
have to come out you don't have to
struggle
with
um knowing your place finding your Niche
understanding who you are being accepted
people are never in danger for who they
love how they present
um how they live their lives
um and even though bad things happen in
my books it's not gonna be that and the
reason for that is because I want
um queer readers to be able to pick up
my work and know that I am not going to
hurt them in that way the real world
hurts us enough
in that way
um if we are actually going to believe
that the future is good that obstacle as
far as I'm concerned needs to be removed
from it that doesn't mean we shouldn't
tell stories about queer pain that
doesn't mean we shouldn't tell stories
about queer tragedy but in my work for
my part
um
what I find to be
the most powerful thing I can do when I
am scared when I am hurting
is to write a world in which that kind
of hurt doesn't exist anymore and it's
it's not hard to do
I think we've both uh both proven that
in our in our stuff that you can just
exist as you are and it doesn't have to
be as difficult as it is yeah I think
thing that I really like about what I'm
calling ambient queerness which can mean
having characters having situations
about having
a character like characters who are gay
or lesbian or bisexual it's also about
imagining different ways that people
might have relationships with each other
they might be polyamorous they might be
asexual they might have like one gender
today and like six genders tomorrow they
might not even think of gender as an
important binary like if you have a
character who's a train like gender is
not really a thing right like the train
is having a romance with a cat so like
okay there's your genders cat and train
um and then of course you know now you
know where the cat bus comes from in My
Neighbor Totoro
um that is I seriously I did that okay I
did that for you
um but I so it's about imagining like
radical new forms of otherness that
aren't demonized that are just like fun
and cozy and and that's been baked into
science fiction from the jump if you are
talking about a a genre in which we have
aliens we have robots we have sentient
trains uh and these are all par for the
course it just becomes ridiculous that
you wouldn't have
all these different structures of these
social structures of gender family sex
all the rest of it it it's part and
parcel of the of this style of
Storytelling uh and so it lends itself
very naturally to just being a place
where you can explore all these things
and make it as easy as pie
um and that's one of the things I love
about it so much yeah
okay so on that note now we've gotten
cozy we've gotten queer we've embraced
nature
please you can ask questions I know we
have questions on um the live stream as
well so
um
sure
oh did you want to ask sorry
yeah sorry we need you to speak into the
mic so that people on the internet can
hear you my internet would you help me
write a story to tell about the
differences between subjective dystopia
and objective dystopia
how much time
short story oh I'm terrible at short
stories Emily you want to take this one
I feel like I'm being asked to do Free
Labor here I don't know
laughs
um I think I mean I think it's
interesting to think about subjective
and objective dystopia though because
the difference is obviously what one
person experiences is a horrific
situation versus something that's
collectively experienced and I think
right now we have a great example of of
a collective trauma that we've all been
through which is the pandemic and so
that I think we can start to recognize
just by knowing like feeling that how we
all felt that together in different ways
that feels very different from like a
personal tragedy and so I think that's
kind of the seed of thinking about those
two different things and of course they
often coincide right like you know
obviously a collective trauma can lead
to lots of personal traumas and of
course it did so yeah thank you
oh hello Fred oh yeah
um
I really enjoyed your comments uh very
thoughtful and uh I must say that I
pretty enjoyed the tone of it
um uh my name is Peter Schwartz I'm one
of the founders of long now and I've
written seven books on the future and
about four feature films uh and I've
struggled with the problem that you talk
about dystopianism is intellectually
lazy because it's easy to write how
things go wrong it really is not hard
right things breaking down is an easy
story and so all of these movies and
books that are inherently dystopian I
see is intellectually trivial
uh you said it was easy to imagine a
better future I think it's actually very
hard uh one that is believable so a
number of years ago Pete Lyden my friend
here and I wrote an article in wire to
cover story called The Long boom lots of
music no it can't possibly happen of
course it did uh help write a movie
called Minority Report
which started out as a very optimistic
view of the future but it got colored
with a tone
but if you looked at the world of
Minority Report it was actually quite
optimistic people were living well uh it
was actually free and open the
surveillance Society was the dark
element of it and it was the essence of
the story but the context was remarkably
positive yet no one reacts to it that
way and I'm just curious in terms of the
reaction to your respective fictions
do people simply say no it can't
possibly go that way it's a failure of
imagination on their part that they
cannot imagine that you could be right
about a much more optimistic view of the
future
I wish I had a longer answer to this but
the short answer is no uh I have not
encountered much of that have you
um you know I think mostly what I've
encountered is that people often want to
read dystopia into stories where it
isn't intended
um and also vice versa
um I I don't I mean but I and I think
that's part of what you're talking about
is people kind of project onto it what
they what they want to see yeah I think
um what I've actually found very
heartening uh is how
hungry I have found readers to be for
those hopeful Futures I think um there
are a lot of people who get turned off
of Science Fiction because they see it
as the genre of dystopia and if you can
hand them an example that of something
that says actually no we've got all
kinds of stuff in here
um people react very positively to that
I think a lot of people just want to be
told a story in which
things are okay as I've said and um so
uh maybe I've just been lucky and the
folks I'm talking to
um but
if I find that people are not only
hungry for those stories but extremely
receptive to the idea of that future
being possible
yeah we have a question from the live
stream here topical question from Leon
um stanudz
um what
what can we all be doing to build
emotionally morally and spiritually
intelligent artificial intelligence
well you could start paying all of those
Raiders and people who are helping to do
quality assurance on your large language
models you could start hiring them as
full-time staff and giving them health
care benefits
um you could start treating you know the
workers who are designing all of these
systems with integrity and honor and
start worrying about the actual problems
like you know
racism and sexism that are built into a
lot of these models I mean I think
there's a lot of actually super easy
answers to that question and we keep
kind of knocking ourselves ourselves
over the head saying like wait but we
have to do something to the code and
it's like it's not the code buddy it's
the human beings who are writing the
code those are the people that you need
to treat with Integrity those are the
people who need to be lifted up and then
you know we'll worry about the other
stuff
tools will always reflect the people who
make them is what it comes down to and
if those people are exhausted
and poorly treated uh and if the people
overseeing those people are
how to put this
fascists yeah
um you're gonna end up with racist
robots like that's just what's gonna
happen so I I completely agree start
with the people
amen uh I'm curious what you each think
about villains
um I was struck I loved Wayfarers all
the books thank you so much
um and I was struck at the absence of
the here is an evil doer who has just
wants to rule the universe for no
discernible reason other than their
evilness
um the total absence of that kind of
villain so I sort of wonder how do you
guys think about villains and
where they fit into the kinds of stories
you want to tell
I don't know any villains personally so
therefore I find it very hard to write
about them uh and with with Wayfarers in
particular
um I wanted to tell a story about
Ordinary People I wanted to tell a story
about the Everyman
um that just happened to live in a you
know fantastic Galactic future uh and
since I don't know any villains I
figured most people don't uh and that it
would be a more realistic believable
story even though you are talking about
you know punching wormholes and you know
a giant uh otter looking dudes and you
know all the rest of it
if you just have people doing their best
because that's generally speaking
the sorts of people that we all know
um if I ever decide to write a big let's
go do drugs and ride sand worms sort of
Space Opera maybe I'll change my tune on
that
um but for for for now at least I prefer
keeping my stories villain free
I love that and answer that it's just
this practical thing of like who knows a
villain you know like that's not it's
not realistic mustaches aren't even
really that in fashion anymore it's very
difficult yeah to be and our trains are
a mess you can't tie anybody the tracks
these days I know that's actually a huge
disappointment I I would add to that
um I I've actually been called out a few
times where people will say like you
know I just feel like the villains in
your books are just not filled in enough
um you know I want to know more about
the villain
um and I I have to say that I just do
not give a about how bad people
justify what they're doing to themselves
like what the hell difference does it
make okay they're telling them people
always like to say in the fiction
Community like but villains always tell
themselves that they're doing the right
thing I'm like again do not care I don't
know what are they telling themselves I
just don't know it's not worth my time I
think what is important is to understand
what people are doing that is
destructive so if someone in a position
of power is doing destructive things
yeah we need to know what they're doing
we need to know how to push back against
them we need to understand patterns in
like how you can defeat someone who's
doing something destructive using the
law or using you know physical
resistance or using psychological
techniques whatever you're going to use
to defeat your bad guy but I prefer to
have a villain if I have a villain or if
I have a bad guy to just be like yeah
they're over there doing terrible things
let's focus on how we're stopping them
and not worry about whether they had a
sad childhood or whether they're doing
this out of a sense of vulnerability who
cares you know what we all have a sense
of vulnerability lots of us had shitty
childhoods we didn't grow up to like you
know oppress a bunch of workers and
underpay them like it's just not you
know we didn't all go there so yeah
sorry about that I just don't I don't
care about villains
hi
um
hey
um one thing that I think about when I
think about resistance sometimes is
parity and like commentary through
parody uh do you think there's a place
for that in your idea of how to resist
dystopia and do you think maybe there's
parody that you could find in in the
works that you've brought in the world
at 100 uh the more you can laugh at the
things that scare you and hurt you the
more you rob them of their power
um I think that parody is a is a very
particular art form that takes a very
special skill set in order to pull it
off it's not something I have brought
into my work because I don't have access
to that toolbox
um but I think that yeah absolutely like
parody satire all of it um these are
extremely effective tools uh in the the
the grand fictional ecosystem and yes
they absolutely have a place in this
yeah I think so too
um I
I actually like I mean I actually feel
like you you have a lot of wholesome
humor in your books and I really like
that I feel like we're having a moment
in culture right now where like
wholesome humor is a big thing like I
feel like Dad jokes are the sort of
utopian pushback against like nasty
satire and um I'm just yeah so I'm I'm
happy to live in a world of of dad jokes
oh
um how did in your opinion how did we
get here like why aren't we sitting here
at a at an event that's saying resisting
you know kind of Utopia like the oh
dominant ideas utopian and where it's
like the kind of critics that are trying
to like poke holes at it or why isn't
this kind of the kind of the 50 50 split
you know how do we tip it towards you
know Utopia I mean
is it in human nature is it our era that
we just happen to be cynical now but you
know 50 years from now it won't be that
or 50 years ago was different I'm just
curious like how did we get here and
that's kind of a with an insight to how
do we get out of it
I think
[Music]
um
my answer to that is is
perhaps what it isn't is my best answer
to that it's not human nature and I I
firmly believe that
um all you have to do is study the
history of
human civilization of different cultures
around the world of places that do not
exist within
um Western colonialism Western
capitalism and you will find cultures in
which
people
loved each other I don't know how else
to put that people where people cared
about each other more than about
things and about war and about all the
other things we find ourselves mired in
I really believe that it is
um just the era we are in I think that
um
I I don't like being here anymore than I
think
um a lot of us do but no I think that
humans are inherently good I I and maybe
that's uh naive of me but I really do
believe that I believe that humans are
inherently good we want to help we want
to uh hold each other up and
what we're denied is the the time and
the freedom to do that and we've been
denied that a very long time and it's
it's a death by a Thousand Cuts you know
um and so I think as to how we get out
of it
I don't know
um
if anybody knows please speak up
but how did we get here I think by not
by believing that it won't be different
by constantly believing that this is all
there is by believing that it is human
nature but believing that the end will
always be Grim that is how we got here
that's how we'll stay here but if we
push those boundaries be it through
Reading science fiction be it through I
don't know learning a different language
going you know talking to somebody from
a different place picking up a book on
literally any topic you don't know about
it opens your mind to new avenues and
the more we just continually reinforce
this idea of it does not have to be like
this
that's how we get out I think or maybe
not I don't know yeah I think that's
right and yeah
um I would just add that uh I think we
are also in a sense trying to resist
Utopia here too because I think we're
both
trying to push back against this idea of
a binary like that it's either perfect
or horrible and that there's someplace
in the middle and I think that place in
the middle is the solution and where and
what it feels like is acknowledging that
we're going to screw up over and over
again and forgiving ourselves I think
that's one of our big problems as a
species is that when we mess up
especially in the west we feel like okay
well I'm just a bad person and
everything is broken and it will always
be broken and it can't be fixed and so
one of the things that I really strive
for in my fiction and my storytelling
and in my work outside that is to remind
people that like we can fix stuff like
even if it's incredibly broken
incredibly screwed up there's always a
way to fix it no we're not going to fix
it all at once it's not going to happen
overnight we do need these long time
spans but every little bit helps and so
I'd love to see a a posture of let's get
it done let's fix it together instead of
let's figure out who screwed this up who
did it who was the bad guy all right
send him to jail send her to jail and
it's like what if we just said all right
everybody chill out pick up a tool
whatever tool and or just take a nap you
know that's okay too and let's just do
what we can I think the problem with
Utopia is that it it lends itself to the
idea that there will ever be a
one-size-fits all yes oh my gosh for
everything uh and there won't be the
work will never ever ever be done we
will constantly be fixing things because
there's no escaping entropy everything's
going to break and you just have to
accept that
there will never be an end right you
just have to keep going and I think that
this idea that we'll just figure it all
out one day
we won't we're gonna
keep disagreeing too that's the thing
and like you know it's very common to
say like you know one person's Utopia is
another person's dystopia and that's
gonna continue being the case and so as
we're working toward having a world
where you know things are better and by
better I just mean like you know
everybody has food like everybody has a
place to live everybody is protected
from disaster
um you know we are going to keep having
those conflicts and it's going to be
ugly and people are going to be sad and
you know we're never going to reach a
point
we're animals right we're always going
to have suffering but we can create a
world where that suffering is eased
because we have a community that's there
for us and I think that's really the
goal
I think we have time for one more
question
um yeah oh even waiting for ages yeah
guys
um Andrew core of San Francisco resident
um designer here in the city uh I wonder
if you're familiar with the work of
Monica bielskai Chi Champions the idea
of protopianism which is really like
what can we do as like through design
fiction and painting a picture of a
positive future through video games
through comic books like what can we all
do together to help paint this more
positive future as opposed to either
Utopia or dystopia right it's this
Middle Ground kind of saying hey
protopia which is just positive future
maybe we could comment a little bit on
that
just write books yeah sounds good
write good books make good video games
make the thing you want to make and
don't feel like it has to fulfill some
big lofty goal just write a story for
the sake of writing a story because
stories are fun and fun having fun is
resistance having fun is rest having fun
in the midst of everything falling apart
around you is I think one of the most
powerful ways to fight back so just make
stuff make good stuff and share it with
other people yeah have fun take a nap
share some tea with a friend remember
you know you could be changing the
future by being there for a friend you
have no idea what the knock-on effects
are going to be from that you know it's
it's actually a big part of building a
better world so yeah and and also buy
some drinks support support your local
institution
all right well thank you so much thank
you everyone
that was so awesome
thank you everyone we're gonna reset the
room really quick so people stand up if
you make sure to grab your glassware
um and we will stack our volunteers will
stack the chairs but um thanks for
coming out tonight
[Music]
oh